- ah man don't headin vill come into the
gun show the show watched and adored by
millions around the world every day in a
sinister alternate history timeline
[Music]
today we're taking on Wolfenstein the
new order to show you easy ways to
unlock perks smart ways to wield your
weapons and sick as hell ways to kill
Nazis but first a word from our
protagonists hey kids
William blaskowitz here all the gameplay
you see in this fine American video was
captured on uber difficulty why because
Nazis that's why also because the host
is probably trying to compensate for
some kind of childhood trauma I think
I'm very sick this is normal
it's just nurse what did you turn him
down for okay thank you BJ that's quite
enough it's time for you to get back to
battle buddy so we can kick off this
episode of the gun show the first gun
you get into your meaty ham hands is
this submachine gun which we will talk
about in this video for an amount of
time proportional to the amount of time
you get to use it in the game and we're
done better to spend your time with the
assault rifle anyway the single shot
mode is great for popping domes and it's
got better iron sights to aim down
though honestly BJ blaskowitz is so
crazy accurate that you don't really
need to zoom in as long as you can put
the head inside of the parentheses
puh-puh-puh PEMDAS make sure to score at
least a few ad s headshots though
because it'll help you unlock a perk
that makes headshots even more damaging
it doesn't matter much with these
chuckleheads but you might appreciate it
once the big boppers come a-knockin
that's kind of how most perks are not
hugely impactful but nice little rewards
nonetheless if you're playing on uber
difficulty lack of balls you should try
to pick up as many perks as you can in
the early going stealth kill all five
dudes in this particular section of the
trenches and you unlock the ability to
throw knives like a boss find isolated
soldiers and sprint slides straight atom
blasting all the way and earn faster
sprint speed while dual wielding lugga
bombs these small bonuses can make the
difference between slaughtering uber
Nazis and get
so dead tired that you just got a lie
down and take a nap like a cute all
right these oldie timey weapons are all
well and good but let's fast-forward to
the swinging 60s and get a taste for the
guns that come in new zesty orange
flavor the pistol has a nice Ratatat
burst fire thing going on and when
you're dual wielding it's more like a
submachine gun than two individual
pistols so don't be afraid to whip these
out in a pinch of course the real
utility you get out of your sidearm is
thanks to the silencer stealth and
wolfie times is never an assessee but
it's always a good idea to at least try
to pop commander silently before getting
loud if you can't dome with the pistol a
few quick body shots will do or you can
hit them where it really hurts in the
foot the only thing Nazis hate more than
a knife in the butt is traffic duty
outside the Senior Center those
crotchety old geezers will do literally
anything to get out of a ticket one of
the mainstays of the Nazi Arsenal is the
assault rifle and it's easy to see why
it's accurate holds a lot of bullets and
is light enough for a severely atrophied
coma patient to carry one in each hand
this is your go-to for popping in and
out of cover with that sweet lean
mechanic and playing peek-a-boo I killed
you with your enemies when you go dual
wield full auto the fire rate gets so
intense that enemies who aren't
immediately shredded to bits often get
staggered and then shredded the bit and
once you get the rocket launcher
attachment Achtung Baby pop two shots
into a super soul dot in' and watch the
jibs fly alternatively you could just
hit these hulking goons with the I don't
have time for this maneuver in which you
just walk out the door of this sewer
chamber or just hop on this train and
drive away leaving the big lugs to
contemplate their own horribly mutilated
existence in peace who says BJ is only
capable of violence it could be the fact
that he's the biggest goddamn Nazi
machine ever to walk the planet I've oh
right everybody and speaking of violence
perhaps the most badass action hero a
gun in Wolfman Stein is the shotgun more
specifically two of them blam-blam-blam-
in your way through Berlin with these
babies is satisfying on so many levels
aural visual destruction dismembered all
like with the assault rifles dual wield
full auto can stagger tougher enemies
like the shot gun toting heavies but you
got to go for the face and hold down
both triggers with regular ammo unless
you can isolate an enemy to pull this
move one on one though it's best to work
that lean or better yet use shrapnel
shells to bounce blast them from around
the corner of course you can get bounce
blasted yourself which is one of the
more frustrating ways to die in the game
to relieve such frustrations in a
healthy way
I suggest finding an inanimate object
and shooting the crap out of it you put
a Nazi on look you
if you need to aim it something
significantly smaller than the nearest
celestial body then the marksman is
where it's at at first it's pretty
refreshing to be aiming through proper
site and picking off not so's from a
distance but I don't know the thing I
always appreciated about BJ was his
personal touch the way he gets right up
close to you during combat the way he
tucks people in for a nap the way he's
so good with animals the way he makes my
coffee just the way I like it and the
way he takes the time to look I mean
really look at what's inside someone's
heart that's why I was thrilled to
discover what the marksman's alternate
fire is how I don't want to spoil
anything for you but I'm totally gonna
spoil it right now it's lasers
back-to-back lasers can kill dudes for
sure but they're also really helpful for
taking out the big mechanical bad guys
like the really nasty ones that just
marched rigidly out of your nightmares
and are getting really close now so baby
you should run oh god run ah just
kidding we all know the kinds of
nightmares BJ has are the ones where he
has to poop real bad and the chamber pot
is 2-dimensional fortunately you don't
have to wait until your double order of
moon rakers shows up to have some laser
fun thanks to the trusty laser craft
book it's pretty good at damaging robots
very good at gybing meatbags and ultra
good at financing college for the
children of nazi fence makers and chain
writes the various upgrades you pick up
along the way all helped a little bit
though I think the best one might be the
site that autotargets your enemies and
sends charged-up blasts zipping out in
multiple directions this move does
consume a ton of ammo but it also makes
it easy to unlock the perk that requires
you to empty a fully charged laser
Kraftwerk without missing all right that
about covers the weapons you'll be
wielding so I'll just leave you with a
few do's and don'ts for surviving on
uber difficulty lack of balls do make
sure your guns are all fully loaded for
dual wielding before going into any
fight don't stay in one place for too
long waiting for the Nazis to come and
overwhelm you
to sleep in the safe house every chance
you get to earn some health upgrades
don't make the mistake of sliding to be
slick when you could just sprint and be
safe do attempt long-distance knife
kills while yelling from downtown don't
get cocky it's gonna get Rocky dude eat
dog food when low on health because your
regeneration actually makes it worth 20
health points instead of just 4 don't
eat dog food because you're a human man
god damn it where's your sense of pride
that's it for the gun show folks hope
you had some fun
leave some tips of your own in the
comments and help us all avoid the fate
of a horrid alternate timeline
something-something joke damn I really
thought I finished this script last
night
[Music]
you